I had a long interest in physics and the
masses our since middle school but I was
discouraged to choose this too as my
major when I go to college and that's
because my family think that I would
have a hard time to find a job with this
major as a female based on what we saw
at that time in China so instead I
choose biology as my major and it opened
a new door for me it actually provided
the foundation for makanda research and
it also needed me to a beautiful world
of evolution and the life science for my
PhD I is choose the computation about
ology because this is a major comeback
my passion in computation and my
interest in biology for non time
observer for computer scientists if they
want you understand the day mathematical
data the needle have a good
understanding of biology for biologists
if the one speedy discovery the require
the help of computer scientists and my
background saw the bridges gaps a single
work under the brightest stage where we
can actually have the ability to turn
data into action items that can be
directly applied to medical decision
making data science and
combined to improve our health um is one
of the few places where I can start my
researcher program in data science there
is a critical mass of truly exceptional
and the top Nietzsche scientists here
and also fun people
I am approachable front a director to
the top scientists you can just look on
the door and talk with them and they are
always willing to help um is the place
where I can do the research I love and
enjoy and also make a difference at the
same time
[Music]